so guys as we know the reports of Andrew
not actually having cancer but was
unsure how true this was due to Andrew's
team not mentioning anything however
Andrew's manager has just posted on his
Instagram story saying good news team
Romanian news saying Tate actually did
have the biopsy that that Dubai
specialist recommended it was done a
month ago in Bucharest reports Dumas as
his Ben engine be really nice if this
was leaked earlier family and friends
were extremely concerned Romania
wouldn't lie about this so he's okay
it is interesting because like the news
came out that Tate had cancer and like
it seemed like nobody really gave a
like I didn't see it on my feed that
like that much really maybe it just
wasn't really
he had cancer it came out that he might
have cancer that he was going so it
wasn't like official news yet that it
was like terminal cancer like that's
different yeah it was that he was he had
a lesion on his lung that he was being
tested for and he did a biopsy everyone
knows like it's top G like you know God
chooses the way you go out like you're
not just gonna go out to lung cancer I
don't know I don't buy it okay what do
you what are you talking about you have
not been alive long enough I don't buy
it it has confirmed it I'm really happy
likey says many fans were extremely
concerned for Andrew's wealth and how
far now that he actually went to the
hospital in Bucharest and as a test and
he says his cancer is absent honestly
it's absolutely fantastic news guys
comment your thoughts Down Below in the
comment section it's great news it's
great news and it and it also is it
answered all the questions that we had
earlier when we watched the other video
like what's up in Romania if they're not
giving him Medical Care and they were
Andrew's cool Andrew tweeted this I do
not have cancer my lungs contain
precisely zero smoking damage in fact I
have an eight leader leader yeah that's
what I thought but I didn't want to get
that wrong and sound stupid I have an 8
liter long capacity and the vital signs
of an Olympic Athlete there's nothing
but a scar in my lung from an old battle
true Warriors which guard both inside
and out and then here he said as one of
the most influential men on the face of
the planet it's important for the good
of humanity that I live as long as
possible at my current strength levels I
estimate to survive for at least five
thousand more years with this in mind I
take my medical care extremely seriously
I had a regular checkup organized in
Dubai the doctors were extremely
interested in the scar in my lung they
did not understand how I survived
without treatment they do not know the
secrets of udon but this battle has long
passed what is all this wudon stuff he
talks about it's it's stories
um about life that he wrote with his dad
okay I see in his emails the the wudon
stuff but I really didn't know what I
thought it was some you know old fight
train you know ancient fight training
thing that existed but it's all on his
head okay very cool one of the things
that I've learned a lot about in the
past couple years is discipline get
control of your head control your mind
and learn discipline and so you stop
talking yourself out of things and so
you know Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we
work with I went through his 21 day
challenge where he gave me some tasks to
do every day and part of the challenge
was to wake up every day commit to doing
it and every time I started to talk
myself out of it I would have an excuse
run through my had some lame ass excuse
and there are four main excuses that he
teaches people that are that ruin lives
that's why we're doing the 21 Day
Challenge again together which Sunny is
not excited about because he's going to
have Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool but like it
makes you think like if God is like
choosing I mean I guess we're not the
ones to to deem what God chooses but
like
how is God going to kill Tate with lung
cancer when he's like spreading so much
good and like literally like the the
best Force for young men in such a long
time like waking people up sometimes
when people are assassinated they become
Martyrs and they their their message
spreads even further and explodes yeah I
guess it's all part of the plan so
whatever whatever his plan is for Tate
and Tate's message it's going to play
out very interesting and then this part
where the doctors were interested they
don't understand how I survive without
treatment The Matrix doctors man they
don't get they don't get the tales of
udon you know they don't get it very few
understand
see that doesn't make sense I don't have
cancer I'm fine there's a scar on my
lung they don't understand how I survive
without treatment what do you need
treatment for that that leaves in a
question if it's not cancer why what do
they say you need treatment for well
there's a couple possibilities here one
of them is you know he could just be
like not like capping but like what
would be the word for it I don't know
being like you might be exaggerating for
the Tweet another thing is um you might
actually have had something in his lung
that was that was dangerous like there's
plenty of scenarios where people go to
the doctor and the doctor's like I don't
know how you were dealing with this for
so long this is the worst I've seen like
I hear that all the time I feel like
I've heard that story like a million
times from different I know but he's
saying he's got I don't know I'm saying
leader lung capacity and he's a machine
and everything is great no I know but
I'm saying I hear it all the time where
it's like I don't know how you were like
running on this so long like this is
crazy and it's like bro I feel like I've
heard this with so many different people
you know what I mean but and then the
other thing is like he's not saying what
the problem is I just hear what you're
saying but it it doesn't quite this
doesn't lie up here all right whatever
it's interesting maybe he's alluding to
something and raising a question on
purpose my point that I was getting at
is like how with your mind like stuff
that you would think is impossible to
cure without medicine and stuff people
will cure with just their mind
absolutely because the way they believe
it so I think that's kind of what that's
what I was insinuating about and like
the way Tate has treated his body for so
long where it's like something like that
wouldn't be the thing to take him down
because he's put himself through so much
hardship and he's shown God that this
isn't how he's going out basically you
see what I'm saying like if I was to
like go through all the he did and
then you get like a little thing in your
lung that might affect the soy boy a
thousand times more than you your mind
has tremendous power and you and yes but
he's not acknowledging an illness so
that's what not making sense but that
separate conversation of yes somebody
that is weak and terrified and just
focuses on that the tumor growing in
them yeah that tumor is gonna you know
you're gonna have a harder time healing
so you're right you you make sense in
that regard
you're so handsome I just it's just
crazy I can't I just have to kick girls
down the stairs all day long get them
away from us absurd it's crazy beats me
they all want to be my daughter it's
gross look at the chin I do love the
chin it's my favorite all right are you
good you don't look at you you're almost
blushed yeah you blushing you get any
more DMS from any non-skanks of course
let's see the new ones no what's did you
talk to the other one the one I liked
yeah I gotta text her back speaking of
that I'm bad about texting girls man I'm
really bad with it I don't know what to
text them about it's like it's so boring
it's like the same dull conversations
like I'm not a texter so get on the
phone I don't want to call you either
like I have to do I don't want to
just like five minute phone call itself
so it it illuminates a lot of texting
it's good advice I should do that with
these oh my God and you know how much
you stand out that you're not the guy
texting oh my God in today's day and age
when everybody is afraid to make a phone
call and you stand out because you're
the guy that's got the nerve to pick up
the phone and call them yeah you guys
don't even know what it was like you
went back in my day you had to call the
house phone that everyone in the house
shared and there was a good chance that
the mother or the father was picking up
and you had a call and ask a dad to talk
to his daughter
okay and now guys are afraid to even
communicate to call her on my little
cell phone and her direct to her direct
line in her pocket and they're afraid to
call her man you should you know what
the transgenders are right just cut off
your balls because you don't use them
anyway none of you I'm saying I'm not in
person I'm not uh texting and um calling
person well don't go showing up at their
doors try calling first
of course
never do that all right thank you so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfaz and I'll see you later follow
me on Twitter said he never says that
oh my God
[Music]